od the octopus swam home he swam at a
constant speed he plotted how far he'd
gone every 1/7 of a second is a little
tight boy this should just be 1/7 of a
second on the graph below
not all octopi can create graphs but OD
was no ordinary octopus and actually
octopi are some of the smartest
creatures on this planet what was owed
ease speed after after probably dolphins
and and great apes and probably most
primates and but but they're still
fairly smart smarter than most fish what
was owed ease speed in meters per second
note we use m /s to show the units of
meters per second meters per second all
right so to figure out speed to figure
out speed in meters per second we
essentially need a fit we need to divide
a distance in meters distance in meters
divided by time in seconds time in
seconds so let's see if we can pull that
off so the easiest thing let's let me
find a point that I can clearly read how
far
Odie has traveled so it looks like this
point right over here it's clearly that
the distance in meters is 4/7 so let me
do that so the distance in meters is 4/7
so I'll do that in the numerator the
distance in meters see I don't like that
convo I'll just go with this color even
though the contrast with the white
background is a little hard on the eye
and it took him it took him five
sevenths of a second 5/7 of a second to
go there so four sevens meters let me
make sure I put the unit's here for
seventh meters in in five seven five
seven seconds and so literally we just
need to divide 4/7 by five sevens don't
and we're going to get it in meters per
second so this is going to be the same
thing as four sevens over five sevenths
over five sevens meters per second
meters per second
and 4/7 / 5/7 is the same thing as 4/7
times 7/5 so let me write that down
so 4/7 times 7/5 dividing by a fraction
is the same thing as multiplying by its
reciprocal so times 7/5 and we get we
get this well this 7 and this 7 and this
7 cancel out you get 4 over 5 you could
have also done that by multiplying the
numerator and the denominator here by 7
if you multiply by 7 multiplied by 7 you
would get 4 fish but either way his
speed and m/s is 4/5 meters per second